this video is made possible by the great
courses plus an on-demand video learning
service you can learn from the world's
best professors on the great courses
plus now if you're enjoying this sort of
video you should really check out some
of their extensive contents on politics
or economics or if you'd like to learn
more specifically about the coronavirus
they've got a lecture all about viral
intelligence it's a great watch worth
checking out
basically the great courses plus is like
a university education but it's at your
own pace there are no tests no schedules
and it's incredibly easy to access PC
tablet phone however you like they've
also got audio streaming which is super
convenient so you can listen and learn
on the move and there are thousands of
lectures to choose from so yes it's
great stuff and you can try for free get
a free trial at the great courses plus
com forward slash visual politic or
click the link in the description below
doing that help support this show and
let's get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
the European Union is the perfect
scapegoat when things go well in a
European country national governments
like to take credit but when things go
wrong or well it's Europe's fault
this applies equally to both left and
right governments during these days of
quarantine and coronavirus we have all
heard the same complaint how is it
possible that the European Union has
done nothing to help in this crisis and
the question the real question is what
could it do I'm serious I mean think
about it for just a moment for example
health budgets are the responsibility of
individual nations and the same goes for
health care systems many people think
that the whole of Europe has a
completely public health system but that
is not true in fact there are two major
models of health care the Bismark model
and the Beveridge model the Bismark
model is based on public and private
insurance agencies before example I live
in the Czech Republic and I have to
choose an insurance company prices are
regulated by the state so if I have a
problem tomorrow I can choose a private
hospital and my insurance covers all or
part of the treatment that's the Bismark
system however if I lived in Spain the
state would cover the full cost of the
treatment since I could not choose the
hospital
[Music]
that's because they have the beverage
model which is based on the British
model and health budgets differ as well
for example intensive cab in Germany
they have 29 intensive care beds per
100,000 inhabitants in Spain it is nine
point seven and in Finland it's six
point one but that's not all let's
examine the main measures for combating
coronavirus well we're already seeing
quarantine self-isolation coordinating
the police closing borders and well
they're all national measures where
Europe does have a role is in
recommendations and warning systems and
you can already see that some member
states such as Spain choose to disregard
March 8th marches were held against the
European Union's criteria however there
is one way that the European Union can
help and that's the economy and this is
certainly no small matter no one knows
what the world will be like after the
coronavirus crisis but one thing is very
clear we are going to suffer a recession
of immense proportions we have paralyzed
all our productive machinery for several
weeks many companies that were already
stretched going to have to shut up shop
and that means thousands of unemployed
workers I'm sorry to tell you we've got
a very very bad year ahead of us not
only in Spain or in Europe but basically
the whole world
[Music]
coronavirus record number of Americans
file for unemployment as you can imagine
governments are going to have to draw up
a plans credit facilities for companies
tax exemptions or subsidies paid
directly to citizens some countries such
as the Czech Republic have already
announced that for a few months that
self-employed will not have to make
Social Security payments in conclusion
the final bill for the coronavirus
crisis is going to be very steep so how
exactly is it going to be paid well very
simply by generating debt governments
around the world will have to release
lots of debt bonds into the market and
here in Europe they've already dusted
off an old idea euro bonds the idea of
Euro bonds is this instead of each
country taking out its own debt bonds
Europe draws of bonds that encompasses
all members Europe and Italy are looking
forward to something like this however
not all countries agree on this strategy
so listen up
[Music]
Germans in Dutch set to lock you Corona
bonds at video summit and I know you
might be thinking you've seen this movie
before this is one chapter or in the
continuing saga of northern Europe
versus southern Europe the countries of
the north are in favor of austerity in
the countries in the south are in favor
of spending money as if there's no
tomorrow again we return to the tension
within Europe and believe me we're not
talking about empty words for example
Portugal's Prime Minister said that the
Netherlands stance is disgusting and the
Spanish media has already started
preparing their keyboards against the
Netherlands and Germany so the question
is are we really talking about
solidarity are Holland and Germany
really the bad guys in this movie the
what extends our euro bonds or as they
are now called corona bonds a good
solution for the corona crisis while
today we're going to answer these
questions but first let's take a look at
some history
new challenges old formulas the 2008
financial crisis was met with a debt
crisis at the time Portugal Italy Greece
and Spain needed loans and yes I put
them in that order because the
international press called these
countries the pigs not because they were
pigs but because it was p4 Portugal I
for Italy G for Greece and s for Spain
well the pigs needed money and what does
a country do when it wants to borrow
money it usually goes to issue debt
bonds in the market that is you as an
investor buy a piece of paper that says
that Spain or whichever countries turn
it is will refund you what you have been
loaned it interest the problem well
there are countries that simply don't
pay back those debts and believe me if a
company owes you money you have a
problem but if the one who owes you
money is a nation you'd better stop
preying on an example well I'll give you
an example
[Music]
investors brace for losses in Argentine
debt talks exactly thousands of
investors who lent money to Argentina
assume they've lost that money and those
who dare to claim what Argentina owes
them risk being called vulture funds
financial terrorists and many other even
stronger names in this case we could say
that Argentina has a high risk of
defaults so what happens when a country
has high risk of default
[Music]
well you have to pay a higher rate of
interest on the loan in other words I
don't trust that you're going to give me
back what I've lent you but if you
promise me you're going to give me back
a lot more than I've loaned you maybe
I'll be willing to take the risk
that explains why Argentina's 10-year
debt bond has an increased rate of 30
percent since the interest Germany
typically pays is 0.37 percent that's
right if you lends money to Germany not
only do they not give you interest but
you have to pay them and why well
because everyone trusts Germany and
you're probably thinking well how do you
measure a country's risk who measures
this default risk
well this risk is measured by
specialized companies called rating
agencies there are three main ones
Moody's Fitch and Standard & Poor's
these agencies study a country's
accounts its economic structure
companies and calculate how possible it
would be to recover the debt after the
2008 crisis huge countries such as Spain
had huge deficits this meant that the
government was spending a lot more than
it was collecting in taxes add to this
unemployment structural problems and
corruption and Spain has a very high
risk of defaults so well how does that
play out well there's a very high
interest rate on that outstanding debt
to give you an idea in Spain even today
interest on debts is the third largest
item in the state budget in other words
if you're not Germany borrowing money
you can be very expensive but wait a
minute
because there's another alternative
instead of releasing debt bonds into the
markets we can borrow from our friends
in this case the friend is the European
Union yes we're talking about the
dreaded financial bailout
a bailout is a very low interest loan
and you're saved so well where's the
cash
well yes the economic cost is low but
the political cost is very high
basically when the European Union
rescues you it says alright I'll lend
you the money but I'm gonna monitor what
you do with it because you know I don't
trust you and believe me in those years
Europe had every reason not to trust the
pigs for example while Spain was going
through its worst economic crisis Madrid
was promoting itself as a candidate to
host the upcoming Olympic Games that's
not to mention all the cases of
corruption companies that compete for
privileges and the list goes on in other
words the last thing Spanish politicians
wanted was for some gentlemen from
Brussels to be checking their accounts
during these years the expression men in
black was coined
[Music]
these men in black where the evil
European bureaucrats who came to tell
the poor Spanish politicians what they
had to do and that's when the European
Commission supported by Spain and Italy
came up with the idea of the century
Union Commission proposes euro bonds as
crisis weapon in other words investors
didn't want to lend to the pigs because
they didn't trust them but they did want
to lend to Germany euro bonds would be a
bonds that would combine debt from
solving countries with debt from
unsecured countries I mean it was a way
to hide bad dare since good debt in one
package think about it for a moment if
you're an insolvent country euro bonds
are the best of both worlds you barely
pay any interest and they have little
political costs it's oh good problem
well the problem is that euro bonds are
the same mechanism that led to the 2008
crisis that is the idea of hiding good
debt with bad debt in the same package
as the same tactic used by banks in the
2000s it is the same thing that created
the crisis but that's not all
imagine an investor buying a euro bond
it turns out that many European
countries do not want to repay that debt
so who exactly ends up paying for
everyone well that would be the most of
solvent countries that's why when
Brussels proposed this euro bond
solution Germany the Netherlands and
Finland said well of course they did
euro bonds he said bull we are low on
however the situation has now changed
we're in the middle of the coronavirus
crisis and the ghost of euro bonds rings
out again in Brussels so what's changed
now well let's take a look
[Music]
Transparency no thank you
coronavirus resembles the 2008 crisis in
one aspect it is it every country in the
world but each has reacted in different
ways at the time of making this video
Germany has more than 130 thousand
infected and three thousand dead Spain
however more than a hundred and sixty
thousand cases and seventeen thousand
dead Luxembourg has the highest number
of infected people per capita however
they don't even have overcrowded
hospitals in fact they're already
accepting sick people from northern
France
[Music]
and no it's not a matter of being rich
or poor
for example the Czech Republic and
Poland are less wealthy countries than
Spain or Italy however they are facing
the crisis with barely any deaths of
course we don't know what could happen
in a few days but at this point in time
it seems reasonable that Spain and Italy
must be doing something wrong that's a
shame but that's also something we
talked about a couple of days ago on
visual politic the truth is that like
the 2008 crisis the coronavirus crisis
will be paid off with huge amounts of
debt GDP Falls tax revenues fall and
public spending goes up every state in
Europe is going to have to issue debt
and this is where Brussels comes to the
rescue
[Music]
ECB announces 750 billion euro pandemic
emergency purchase program P EPP and
again we're talking about a bailout with
low economic interest at a very high
political cost
[Music]
because when the european central bank
lends you money it wants to know what
you're doing with it and that translates
into spending cuts and this is where we
get into the most ideological part of
this story both Spain and Italy have
boosted public spending in the case of
Spain the government is a coalition of
socialists with podemos but a Miss is a
political party that emerged in 2014 to
oppose the conditions imposed by Europe
after it rescued Spain it's very hard
two things they are going to accept
those conditions now in other words the
president of the Spanish government
Pedro Sanchez well now if it is a
dilemma either he changes government
partners or calls new elections the
first thing would be very difficult the
second thing would risk being thrown out
of governments and it's a similar story
in Italy in this case we have a five
star movement government a five star
movement is another political party that
emerged to oppose the conditions imposed
by Europe after Italy received bailout
payments again it's very hard to imagine
them welcoming the men in black
in other words it is likely that both
Spain and Italy would have to call new
elections and of course given how both
governments have managed the coronavirus
crisis it's highly likely both
governments would lose so the only
politically viable solution they're left
with is this Rhona bonds could bill
you're about tight together in other
words both the governments of Spain
literally do not want to be held
accountable to Europe they expect help
with no compromises and that's how we
arrived at the tense European
videoconference in the Spanish newspaper
our pace there is a transcription of
some of the most complicated moments it
records how Spain proposed the corona
bonds as the only solution and Angela
Merkel in a conciliatory tone said the
follower
rescue mechanism is a very good
instrument in the end it's the one which
is going to help you don't be so
critical of what you're waiting for are
the corona bond they're never going to
appear my Parliament wouldn't accept it
you're generating expectations that
won't be met and delivering messages of
division angle amiracle german
chancellor of course there are two ways
to view this discussion the spanish
press is spinning it's like Northern
Europe doesn't want to help the South
however there is another way to look at
it we could save that both Spain and
Italy do not want to be forced to call
new elections and are willing to do
anything to prevent it so now the
question is for you do you think that
Spain and Italy should accept Europe's
help even if they have to call new
elections what's more important saving
economic goals or saving political goals
well leave your answer in the comments
below and I really do hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit like if you did
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos also please do check out our
fantastic sponsor the great courses plus
on linking to them below thank you for
watching if you want to learn more about
politics and world affairs and here's
some more of my lovely voice come check
out the reconsidered podcast where we
don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider at WWE consider mediacom or
on Apple or Google Play or your favorite
podcast